what the heck
yeah it's an old vhs copy of the game
that i got
that's a lovely snot
you're just blowing snot all over the
place
yup
this game
does this one this is this so do this
it won't be the worst zombie apocalypse
to be in
uh return of the living dead
what's the return of living dead like
basically the zombies can mock you and
like can talk and they're completely
unkillable
okay i was gonna say um
left for dead
no no no because those you can survive
in that one kind of well only if you're
a carrier
yeah
hey sit still all the audio is just
gonna be you going like this
that's what you sound like when you talk
it's just sound
you've never even seen alien one have
you
i don't think so
what
remember talk loud
make sure the people on the street can
hear you yelling
people on the street can you hear me
and captain down
for a second
now said commander destroyed
i should reach the frontier in about six
weeks
commander shepard got rid of the aliens
okay so anyway look at these sick
awesome cut scenes next gen
what
by the way everyone in space is super
sweaty
like spaceships are really hot it's
weird fan art of liara transit's
arranged or shedford
or shepard
shepard's rape face prefer
or both at the same time
look ripley
i read the case history
because uh
i know
because working in the region where she
went missing
huh
what thumbs up he's a dire wolf never
mind
that's what he's going after
i'm gonna get a white cat named ghost
it's gonna be the
litter and you're not gonna understand
this reference but i don't care it's
just like a call of duty thing or
okay so it's a dire work
so oh yeah
that's how a video game needs to start
look at that bit
look at these rape stations
what was the case in prometheus
that was exactly what that was the plot
of prometheus yeah it was
why did we have a machine that that does
abortions but only works for men
wait was that a thing that was a thing
and for me hold on i see a glowing thing
turn around scrub no no not there
it's in the center
yeah what's that
what put a glass of water next to it
do you have motion sickness yet everyone
we don't think we
need to get right on that and turn to
your left oh my gosh i can crouch yeah
the left no
stop what
you're not calling around
no
you you're a winker
briefcase wank up what are you
are you you
no stop pressing it over and over again
yeah i didn't say yes any of the time oh
are you just sitting there
inserting and uninserting your key card
yeah
absolutely what's the
gameplay
do you want to take off hey did you put
your clothes on yet i'm a rebel
yeah yeah yeah get rekt sign
get rekt
i'm a strong independent woman you don't
tell me what to do i don't need no sign
i'll be as wet as i want to
i'm gonna blur that out
you know what
leave that in that is amazing
wash that horse tank off of ya
from the rape pods you smell like
commander shepherd
he puts a lot of effort into smelling
like a whorehouse
without having to go to a whorehouse
you want to look out for a navigational
officer are you guys sit here and read
this whole i have a friend just lost his
ship and he's looking for work i'm doing
it for the viewers today are you gonna
watch you're gonna keep vouch for him
horrible why would you do that
same old story
yes because whispering it will make it
better
hey items
how come you're finding so many items i
walked through here walked up to that
locker right over there
oh my gosh buttons
wait no no turn back to your left
wait is that pouring on that that table
there
what or that bed what what is that
uh close enough the girl wearing regret
i don't think that qualifies
it did in the 70s
porn was like right down your ankles
by the way don't turn off the water just
leave it on and cost like a thousand
dollars all right go ahead and lock it
you're right great idea
get dressed
porn in the 70s was a lot like ride to
hell retribution you didn't take off
your clothes
oh yeah that's so nice
this game is so happy
where do i go the door
the door the door this one that door
this one right here yes
no maybe
yeah borderlands actually heavily
inspired alien oh yeah
borderlands was
it also 60's action game borderlands the
pre-sequel actually heavily inspired
2001 a space odyssey they in fact they
ripped off some stuff from that game
wholesale
yeah all of like that whole space thing
the plot the main character hal is
actually heavily based on claptrap
that's why they both have one eye
i'm doing
doing the ripley slide now uh come on no
no
you found the lease line then you
hold on let me try something let me try
two objectives i'm taking over oh i'm
taking over this space party oh
i was going to touch a great pace though
gameplay
i've worked engineering jobs on ships
like this
of course yeah i don't know he actually
looks kind of flat down there he's like
a kendall
what if they do have
what would be the point of that
we populate the human race no i mean
they don't have
well they're filled to the brim with
white liquid but not the right one
you seen alien remember when bishop just
explodes and there's
theoretical robot semen everywhere
is that how it works that's how it works
ask the transformers optimus prime is
just filled with milk
files you're not you don't have to want
a good job scavenging you scrub
i'm surprised wayland yutani felt the
need the nastrama
did you read all that good yeah oh you
can't have the controller it's mine i'm
taking over this
taking over this alien party
you've alienated our audience
screw scavenging i got all the stuff i
need i got i got my fists i got lefty
and i got righty right i got rorschach
and deadpool
that's why i named my fists
conversation looks like we're up did you
see that jackson what
here i'll do it again
oh yeah go get the files no give me the
controller ah
it can't be oh okay son no
but this was supposed to be spooky
ripley please come on what are you doing
over there
hey go bang on some computers and scream
mother
mother
oh we've been capturing for like 20
minutes and nothing interesting has
happened i know
can we see it
switch to monitor my defense
sevastopol
is that damage
it looks like damage
punch-ups no waste so much hard drive
space just recording you ticking around
doing nothing
but that video may never come out
recorded unit because the audio mixing
is so bad because you sat 17 feet away
from the microphone
i'd have to go through and then put
subtitles for every single thing you
said which i would never be able to
i hope people
they're all like hey we found that ship
from alien one you don't know what
happened some [ __ ] went down you want to
come hang out ripley and
ellen ripley's daughter amanda ripley's
all i do the spider suits the spider
suits
secretly they're all spiderman
you just gave me the perfect opportunity
to splice in spiderman pictures
yeah but now they're here you can't stop
them
pressurizing like that girl in the
glasses
just shadow me taylor
you too samuel you got a thing for nerd
girls
and one person who's not nerdy who wears
glasses
just keep moving
all girls that have vision problems wear
contacts all guys that have vision
problems either wear contacts or where
they'll wear glasses sometimes
and if either of the cases involve being
a nerd then they just keep the glasses
oh man i got a freaking blur that out
too
no here i'll put those black bars i'll
let them send messages to dominator i'll
put no stop saying his name combinator
one eight eight eight now i have to play
me ripley
believe it or not
i hope we didn't alienate the fan
base.jpg
we can just end the video right here we
don't even have to get to the alien
this is fine this is good just insert
darylface.jpg and then
video done
then that picture of glenn
where he has this like half
sad half happy face yeah where it looks
like he's having some kind of orgasm
yeah just looks like he's going nuts
oh video games
you